I should have had him like a tea hey put
that I'm lazy hey there everybody so I
have caught up on Picard and the last
time we talked about this it was the
first episode and I have now seen
through the sixth episode and this is
not going to be an episode by episode
detailed breakdown review or commentary
this is going to be my thoughts on the
series overall now that we are over
halfway through the first season and I
definitely have overall positive
feelings about this quick reminder my
own relationship with Star Trek I have
always liked it but I've never done a
deep dive into it
really any of the variants of it I know
the classic series best from the movies
I know the next generation best of any
of the series I really haven't seen very
much of ds9 I've seen a little bit of
Voyager I saw one episode of enterprise
and like yeah not for me I haven't
gotten to discovery yet I'm softer on
the reboot Star Trek movies than most
people are and now we have Picard so
Picard opened really well I really liked
episode 1 you can go back and watch my
review of that if you want detailed
information on that but I thought I did
a really good job of giving us a
somewhat darker more complicated look at
this world without feeling like it was
undermining what we had seen up to this
point it didn't feel like it betrayed
the character of Picard it didn't really
feel like it betrayed the world that he
was a part of either Picard was always
the idealist in the world that he
operated in that was I honestly in my
head Canon that's part of why in the
next generation he was put on a ship out
in a five-year mission as opposed to
being you know in the normal speaker of
things he was sent out there like look
go
take your ideals to go out there and
spread those around stop being here and
telling us how we're supposed to do this
work
that's headcanon for me sure but that
sort of conflict was always kind of
there and for that reason I don't even
feel like they're like no they've ruined
the Federation there's all Leo there's
they're not perfect like the Federation
has not always been seen as perfect not
it's not even in TNG the crew of the
enterprise was usually incredibly
homogenous and you might take that as a
microcosm for the Federation but that's
a leap you don't have to make that
assumption and there's a lot of
interesting things being done with the
plan I also like all the stuff that it's
picking up from the series up to this
point I mean a huge part of this world
building is the destruction of the
Romulan home and the mass evacuation
which is what set off the Kelvin
timeline in the reboot like they're
tying in a lot of stuff and surprisingly
organically basically just picking up
the story in the universe where these
things happened and just picking up the
story a bit down the line and we get
references and mentions of those things
then it's very cool and the other thing
that's kind of neat is they have Picard
teaming up with basically a crew of new
characters who are unique to this show
now that's good for a couple reasons the
first is this could have very easily
turned into a reunion show
we still have that to a certain degree
you know we had a cameo from data in the
open the pilot episode at this point if
you haven't seen through episode six
like this probably got to be some degree
of spoilers coming out of my mouth just
like know that okay but you later on you
have seven of nine turning up and
they've teased at the end of this most
recent one that the next episode is
gonna have Riker so you know there is
some of that in there but at the same
time the most of the core cast that is
orbiting around Picard himself are all
which gives this its own flavor so it
has Picard back you know as that moral
righteous a bright forthright right good
guy you know coming in to do the right
thing and because that that's our that's
our pillar that's what everything is
centered around and you've got all the
other characters just sort of in his
orbit they don't have to be the people
we already know and in fact it's
slightly more interesting if they're not
now some of these people he has history
with some of them he doesn't we've got
someone who used to be under his command
when he was still with Starfleet whose
name is Raffy and she's decent
she's good she's got a lot of baggage
clearly there's also the pilot for the
ship there are named Rios who's got a
little bit of a han Solo thing going a
little bit of that devil-may-care
slightly beaten down by the
circumstances of the world thing going
on
we've got Agatha who was the doctor and
who studied synthetic life who I
mentioned back when I talked about the
first episode I was like I like her and
I like that it looks like she's gonna
stick around which she does
there's also Eleanor who is a young
Romulan I can't remember the name of the
order he's a part of they're basically
sort of this warrior monk thing and like
what he is is kind of interesting I feel
like he's the weak link as far as the
characters go though the promise Eleanor
is just very he's very bland and
predictable he doesn't have a lot of
presence the I don't know how much of it
is the performer and how much of it is
the writing but there just isn't a lot
of charisma or screen presence from him
and he kind of needs that because the
characterization is very generic you
know he's it's a bit classic Vulcan even
though he's a Romulan you know the bit
sort of taking everything very literally
and kneading stuff explained to him and
not lying and and and all this sort of
stuff and personality so it's like it's
like they turned Spock into a samurai
but he's he's just kind of bland which
which is a shame because I think some of
the some of the lore at the heart of how
he operates and everything else I
actually think is rather interesting
so that's your that's your core group
but then we've also got over on the
board cube sorry the artifact
we've got Shoji who is the sister of
dodge who died in the opening episode
and Shoji is working to try and help
basically deep program and unassimilated
off members of the Borg collective which
this thing also picks up quite a bit
from the aftermath of the Borg you know
we get mentions of Picard's assimilation
of Locutus and in addition to that
there's some emphasis on nobody trusts X
Borg you know that which you know yeah
it's kind of hard to blame them but it's
like yeah now that that sucks people
don't choose to be part of this thing so
there's that going on and there's uh
who's narak is a Romulan spy type who is
hooking up with Shoji and is basically
trying to extract information from her
now he has the intention to kill her but
he wants to get information out of her
first and he's part of a society that I
I'm curious to know how much more we're
gonna find out about their motivations
on this because right now so far what we
have is just being presented as they
hate all synthetic life and for that
reason they want to kill her and
anything else that might be vaguely
similar to her and I'm hoping we get a
little bit more detail on their
motivation than that because otherwise
it just becomes they are hardcore you
know
mentalists in their belief system and
that's not to say you can't have that as
a villain and you can't have bad as your
antagonist but it's just uninteresting
you know why are they doing this cuz
they really believe that these things
are evil that's that's it that that's
the only thing is driving all this they
just super believe okay I mean like I
said you can do it I just find it's very
dull as a storytelling option to go that
way but part of a neat side effect the
fact that the background I'm sorry not
the background the supporting cast are
primarily new faces it took me a little
time to clock some of the people who did
return and once I did Clark though I'm
like oh that's neat like Maddox the
doctor the professor that they are
spending like the first five episodes
trying to reach and find who was the the
leading expert on synthetic life and
positronic brains and all that who was
the guy from that episode of Star Trek
The Next Generation the measure of a man
where data was put on trial to determine
whether enough he had humanity and would
be allowed to have his own agency this
was the guy who wanted data to lose that
case so that he could pull him apart and
study him that it took me like I said a
couple episodes to finally have that
clip but I was like oh cool and then
later on on the Borg reclamation project
we have Hugh Hugh that's like and again
I didn't catch it right off but I caught
a little bit later and it just made me
smile I like I said all this stuff feels
very organic I really am diggin it the
some of the visuals in this are really
cool as well that there's this great bit
having this this imposed image you know
because of sort of a transparent screen
of Locutus right over
current elder Picard's face and it is
unsettling you can definitely see that
it unsettles him there's some cool stuff
like that it looks good the music's good
I I'm digging the vibe and the feel
there's really only one character that
I'm not really vibing off all that much
but like the show doesn't depend on him
excessively heavily if I had a major
criticism of the thing overall it's that
the pacing is a little too slow for its
own good not to say that you can't have
something that is deliberately pace with
it like this and I'm not saying like it
should be a major action scene every ten
minutes that's not what I'm talking
about I'm talking about the fact that
because we know where Picard and his
crew are trying to get to and more than
that like we know what's there we're
seeing so it's not even like they're on
a quest to find this things like we know
what the thing is we keep cutting back
to it so how long it's taken them to get
there is it doesn't quite jell it would
flow better if we didn't know what the
destination was like because since we
are effectively all already there as an
audience it makes us a little impatient
for the main characters to get there so
that we can we can join up with them
like in my personal opinion I find in
general that I connect most with the
goal and quest and motivations of
characters who I'm on the same page as
and I'm not just talking beliefs I mean
in terms of my knowledge if I know way
more than the characters involved
I get bored or annoyed because I'm
waiting for them to catch up to where I
am and this show does suffer from that a
little bit the the audience is in the
know one way more than any of the hero
characters are a little well at least so
far as we know something's going on with
Agatha I don't really know the deal
there yet I'm then I'm not gonna get
into speculation but overall you know
the
Picard has spent the first five episodes
or so trying to figure out where is this
twin is she even alive how can I get how
can I get there and like well we know
who the twin is we know where she is we
know she's that we know the answer to
all his questions and so we're waiting
for him to catch up and in addition to
that he's still stopping to take detours
to fill out his crew by picking up folks
like Elmore and it's it's just it's just
a pacing that doesn't quite work when we
know as much about the destination as we
do if the destination was more nebulous
you can get away with this but given the
way it is it it is slow in a way that
did not have to happen and is completely
separate from the idea of having a more
thoughtful pacing to the whole thing but
that this isn't quite the issue that I'm
having it's not that it's thoughtfully
paced it's that I don't want to be this
far ahead of the characters so that's
like my one gripe with it but big scheme
considering how many things could have
gone wrong
with this entire concept of moving
things forward having Picard be this old
basically having the story pivot on
data's legacy in addition to all the
stuff going on with the Romulans and
really reminding us what a Cold War
analog they were yeah there's a lot that
could have gone wrong here and that's
really the one massive complaint that I
have with a minor compelling don't one
character I think that's a pretty good
showing so far
I'll be very see how this wraps up once
it does I may do one more video with my
thoughts on it towards the end but for
right now I think I will wrap it up
there Picard you caught up on whatever
your thoughts are drop something down
the comments let's talk about it
bunch stuff to do is well like subscribe
I have a patreon that would be
incredibly helpful and all the usual
stuff but you don't have to do any of
that because the end of the day you're
the council I'm just running the
meetings and intone
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]